there's your wings ma'am and here is
your salad
thank you ma'am oh i mean honestly how
many people do you think's
eating here pumpkin would beat my ass
because she knew i was eating all this
bad foods
the way i show my love is like with food
i mean y'all got to eat y'all got a
drink i want to make sure y'all got
y'all's favorite thing you always got to
make sure somebody fed
there's nothing wrong with showing love
but i mean if we eat healthy
we can live longer be together longer
and love each other longer
do you know when you might have the
diabetes test back
he said in a couple days he told me just
to wait on my test results and then you
told me
like maybe i should start eating better
and maybe make better choices and stuff
look i mean you really do need to keep
on top of the diabetes because
diabetes can kill you if it gets like
progressive
if the test does come back positive then
i'll start eating better
well even if the test results come back
that you don't have diabetes
i mean there's nothing wrong with eating
good and but i mean it is it is hard
dude
i put pumpkin's number on the thing so
they're going to call pumpkin about it
i mean we can take this home to pumpkin
we don't eat it all i mean
she has been eating a lot since she's
been pregnant so how are you feeling
about the baby and all them
i'm happy about it look if that stuff
gets had to get the house and stuff i
mean
we got us like a permanent spot i mean
it's close to the beach but we have
enough room that you can stay there and
like chill out and be like
your getaway from all like the craziness
that's happening here i mean i'd love to
come out down to florida but
have you heard anything about court and
the lawyers and stuff
i ain't even wanting to think about that
i mean i'm pretty
confident it's gonna go in our favor
they're not gonna put mama june
in prison the fact is we both may end up
in jail
i mean that's not what i want but it is
a possibility no and you're talking
about everything might go in your favor
i'm worried for mama because geno looks
after mama but like
if she goes to jail who's gonna help her
then nobody's gonna help her around the
jail cell
you just love to sugarcoat stuff don't
you mama that's her way of dealing with
it dude she don't want to admit it to
[Music]
herself